hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
okay so we're picking up right where we
left off we have food under way we have
oxygen under way we need to get more
oxygen in the future and also we got a
[ __ ] pit here which I call the [ __ ] pit
I bet you'll wonder why cuz it's
[ __ ] okay yeah that's pretty much
the long the short of it anyway it's
where we're gonna dump all of our
garbage and before we dump that we're
gonna make sure that we got this here ah
you just have to rip the roof off of
that re you raised the roof too hard why
would you do that to me
how did you do that to me okay we also
need more research because we're going
under way we can't waste a single
goddamn second with all this [ __ ]
decontamination that's important but not
as important as I think because I want
to get into brute force refinement
because that sounds cool we do need a
refrigerator at some point Oh Animal
Control that's also really important uh
you know what I'm just gonna basically
new I'm gonna pull one of these
maneuvers here
I want the transit tubes I'm not gonna
lie I want those transit to real badly
so I'm gonna let that go and then we'll
have people constantly doing the you
know the situation where they're
researching at all hours of the day and
hopefully that's gonna help us under way
but we need a lot more oxygen we've only
produced 26 kilograms I think it's like
the rule of thumb is you need like two
algae terrariums per per duplicated so
long as they're not mouth breathers so I
need to get eight more of those at
minimum I think that's gonna help me get
to where I need to go yeah I think so I
think he thumb to Lanka I think so I
think I need eight more of those so I'm
gonna go ahead and do that and then I
shouldn't need any more of them okay I'm
gonna put I'm gonna put two down here to
get some of this carbon deok sued so I'm
not gonna do that
two down there let's see right there
because I'm gonna put the airflow tiles
underneath there and one no they'd have
to go in there for that one one I didn't
know if we need two more yeah I guess
I'll put it up here just just to make
sure that there's no like this leakage
of yeah but I'm gonna put a room here
[Music]
you know I really don't care that much
so why not just at the back of this room
here I know that's hard to get water to
it
uh alright you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna connect these two here and
then eventually I'm just gonna put two
more on either side of this and that
that's it and that should be enough for
everybody that should be a nice path for
all the water so that they're not going
everywhere why are you in there Frankie
what are you doing Frankie Frankie get
out of there Frankie Frankie Frankie all
right whatever so we got the airflow
tiles will research more research more
research so then we need to get
refrigeration at some point but if
they're on the path to go over to that
thing maybe I should do this more
piecemeal artistic expression man good
think I got all these good researchers
going on here
oh yeah jobs wait I need to make sure
that the dumbass Frankie doesn't do that
and nobody else does art besides Frankie
because she's a genius at it a letter
that a little
no one's gonna cook besides raw wood all
right NEMA you are a fighting master
okay all right doing good doing good
doing good so the next step I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna make a food facility as
soon as that's done which is very soon
also I'm gonna put a statue in the
[ __ ] uh-huh yeah I probably should
have put at least one of the algae
terrariums in here just a little people
can hold their breath I mean there's
gonna be polluted oxygen in there anyway
so what does it matter as soon as I get
to deodorizer that's what I'm gonna do
for that so I've got enough water for
right now I need to get a filtration
system at some point there's oxygen flow
in there
we've got I'm willing to bet that after
this gets through one more cycle what is
with your red dots of death I don't like
it don't like it none but I'm gonna
create a mess hall up here so that they
have a unified place to eat mmm
I'm gonna need Animal Control at some
point meal prep agriculture let's go for
animal control just so we can get those
hatches out of there then we can put
them into one place and then hopefully
hopefully that means we'll have a
depository 'um of things that we need to
do now I don't know if I can instruct
anyone to put things zum-zum were but if
I put storage containers if I put
storage containers in there they
shouldn't I think they're able to eat
from the storage containers I'm not on
represent sure about that but something
tells me that that is a thing that can
definitely happen I have nothing to base
that off of but my own intuition in my
own
she wrote spa I don't know what quits
plays but I got a lot of it they're
doing that alright time for the mess
hall we're gonna make this so I want the
mess hall to be the biggest lesson that
I've learned in all this is that I need
to stop being such a douche all the time
this is a general statement about my own
life but I need to stop being such a
douche in that I have this really bad
habit of trying to wire the entirety of
my base to one power supply when that's
not entirely necessary I can have small
power supplies which is like that's the
whole point this it's like the lesson to
be learned is these wires will overload
if you power them too much eventually if
you have a heavy watt and a unified
power supply yeah sure
if you have a big project but each thing
can be piecemeal like the mess hall can
have its own power supply I can create
like the the manual generators up here
to power something down there like it's
just that's just what it should be right
you know that's what it should be but I
don't do that because some real dumb
real dumb and then you're just a small
amount of battery and HUBO the big ooh
and then Oh wouldn't you know it we got
ourselves a mess hall going on here
alright so now that we got that I'm
gonna make the furniture is gonna be all
the cooking is gonna be in the back
WAIS block is wouldn't melt don't melt
right though wouldn't that melt I'm
gonna put up I'm gonna pull one of these
in the [ __ ]
there we go that's good and I'm gonna
put a blank canvas over your right ear
there and there no no no no no no no no
no I ain't gonna work like that and
ain't gonna work but I put them right
here and here there we are there we are
now that is refined once we got that
we're gonna make the mess hall with
decoration in mind because these extend
eight blocks so what do we have here an
uneven number [ __ ] yeah I'll just extend
the room a little bit longer
I like symmetry yeah okay so now that we
got that let's establish that the front
end of this [ __ ] is gonna be the
actual eating area with a one two three
fewer we only need five but let's plan
former you know why not why not actually
not not so close to the door we'll have
six because I think eventually I will
have six people six is a nice even
number but for right now I want to make
sure that we got enough to be able to do
what we got to do so that decorum is
gonna be good so in the background here
we're gonna put the refrain badge a door
or also are they researching anything oh
good there okay we're gonna put the
fumble later refrigerators gonna be oh
yeah the refrigerator offers decor as
well so the refrigerator is gonna be
right there and right there we're gonna
know I'm not gonna that's too much power
I forgot that those actually take a lot
of power so a lot of battery on this one
is gonna be a good thing
might as well double up on battery right
off the bat just just in case okay and
then we're gonna need the food prep got
the smack smack and grill right there
that and then the microbe yeah we don't
need two of those and then a little bit
little bit little bit little bit little
bit little bit little bit little bit
yeah we're gonna put ration box back
here because that's gonna be the the
housing for the food
you better be good if I'm gonna get you
you're gonna be good all right Nisbet no
oh God Ruby Ruby oh my god Ruby Ruby
Ruby three negative traits but so many
positive oh my god Ruby you are Ruby you
are a walking disaster Ruby you're just
a walking I like you the tryptophan gas
for phobias squeamish can't aid can't
cook can't dig what can you do Ruby Ruby
what can you do
you've got great cooking skills but
can't cook you can't aid you got
medicine good tinker and in athletics
Ruby you got so much going not going for
it but you know I can't help but like
your Ruby I think I think I can set you
to a very specific purpose you can't do
all these things that's fine you know
that's fine cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna make
I'm gonna make sure Ruby Ruby here
Ruby's Ruby won me over just sheer I
never usually go for people like that
but Ruby something about Ruby look at
that
Ruby can still do a ton of [ __ ] and do
it well so Ruby you ain't gonna do that
you ain't gonna worry about dissing fit
I you can disinfect that's cool that's
true are you ain't gonna worry about
harvesting you sweep you deliver you
maintain repair power hydro fin Ruby's
gonna be a valuable addition to this
team Ruby's got a lot of skills doesn't
have a lot of expectations Ruby I'm
really excited about this Ruby I have a
funny feeling you're gonna be uh
invaluable member to the team all right
so now that we got that underway and all
we need to do now is hook up the power
for these bad boys we get the research
that just finished they're a
blam-blam-blam- what other research uh
control greats
okay that's good because somewhere in
here where's Animal Control don't pause
where's Animal Control whoo fertilizers
is
all righty then I don't know if I need
fertilizer that badly all right animal
control uh aerial creature lure creature
trap I don't have plastic I can't make
any of that [ __ ] I don't have plastic
well that was a waste of my time well
let's go for plastic but I'm not gonna
be able to get plastic because it don't
have anything all this probably needs
plastic I'm not gonna be able to get
plastic let's go for sanitation
decontamination anyway that's that's
always a good one as far as I know so
probably gonna be all right if it's not
then pepper bread stuffed berry I don't
have any of those pickled mule it's
still grizzly why would I do that man I
can't do any of this [ __ ]
mush fry I don't know I don't want that
oh [ __ ] I forgot I need to make another
bed all right I've officially [ __ ]
myself because I keep doing this where I
get like our duplicate duplicate friends
friends friends and it's like there's no
reason to do any of that so the other
thing I got to do is I got to get the
decor in order because things are
looking a bit bleak in here so let's get
this decor up and running so we need to
get let's just strew these bad boys here
here they're here oh look at the
symmetry on that oh I love it I love it
love it love it love it okay so I'm
gonna get you some decor here because
this ain't gonna do nothing for you
all right doodly-doo digital Italy man
these guys are attentive I really do
appreciate it when people are on task
and these guys are on task and you know
what I'm even gonna put a little more a
hey about I know it's I know this is a
little cluttered a lot of the decorum
problems are coming from just this being
cluttered but I will get this underway
whiten the hell what just oh that's why
well that's stupid
god damn it put everything in there get
all of it in the stupid thing and then
sweep this stupid thing
look at this sweat get all this swept
get all that [ __ ] swept sweep it your
sweep that up
alright cuz that's sweeping without
sweeping it ruins a lot of the decorum
so they're gonna go for a bit I'm gonna
leave them to it all I'll just let them
go because they're gonna be good for a
bit we're not doing enough oxygen but
we're close I need to get two more of
those things before we're even out from
the loss of adding the other people so
we need 12 in total basically but we are
still doing pretty decent and just to
put one up here to put one right there
I'm eventually gonna put one right there
[ __ ] I can't make that that's fine I'll
put some lights
where's lice loaf doesn't say it can put
a life what doesn't say can have lice
loaf in here I do want to get the life's
loaf glowing but what's even the point
right I mean to be perfectly honest like
lice is edible and it's not that bad I
mean Ruby's the only one right now
that's causing up a stink and to be
perfectly honest Ruby Ruby you've got
problems as it is
I'll take this as a boon you know kind
of a benefit going on here
I guess oh wait how about yet get rid of
the polluted water oh yeah are we doing
on germs we we death-defying oh no I row
in fro and get that out of your body
right now mister Oh
Rowan goddamnit Rowan get that out of
your body right now did you not wash
your hands did you eat mock root that
was in the [ __ ] hole if you did
you're a sack of [ __ ] yourself and I'm
sorry but you just are alright so I'm
gonna do something risky I'm gonna go
get a drink
hopefully everything's still here when I
get back if it ain't then oopsy poopsy
they all die but I think it'll be good
in fact ah there we go
now they're gonna go for alright
all right are they dead they seem a
little dead ha the oxygen thing I forgot
about that okay we need oxygen flowing
out of one place that is gonna be beefy
enough to get everywhere I'm thinking if
I put one of these yeah one of these
here in the middle ish
oh I pause sorry do air flow tiles
beneath here maybe more like this no no
no that's good kind of like right here
get a power system kind of like one of
these because I don't want them to have
to run in a place that's gonna be shitty
for them also this is gonna heat up that
area okay I could just connect v's I
mean I'm remiss to connect to everything
but I could connect this I do I need to
do though I don't really need to you
know what actually I think I think
because of the decor from the printing
pod which I'm pretty sure bleeds through
that yeah it does
I think it's gonna be okay yes it'll be
fine it'll be fine it won't be that
shitty I'll put another painting it's a
pretty beautiful who's got anything to
worry about that that's beautiful that's
a be a thing of beauty right there all
right
also the decorum is greatly improved
considering that we've gotten rid of all
the [ __ ] that we didn't need it like
the stuff on the floor and now they're
well on their way to success and love
and why alright so once this mess hall
is up and running actually is the mess
hall come on man what does it need one
table no industrial machinery minimum
size 12 no industrial machinery Oh does
that mean like the kitchen
yeah oh yeah I'm not gonna pick anybody
man if I wanted to pick somebody I'd
have to mercilessly murder the one I
didn't want to survive so that I don't
have to go through that they would have
to be they would have to be pretty
amazing liked Rivaldo Auto Lehrer
you guys are good at all and that's
wonderful but you're not amazing enough
for me to have to murder one of my
already their duplicates I don't want to
do that that sounds horrible
and no we're not gonna go for that so
that's all I have to say about that all
right so the only thing I know about
this room is like minimum 12 tiles that
is big that's a honker all right but
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna test this
out I'm gonna get rid of the weight
what's the barracks no industrial
machine but there's no it does your Oh
does that count as an industrial machine
oh wait no it's too big oh why is it too
big
that's stupid you're stupid you know
what I'm gonna get rid of I know how to
beat this I know how to beat the system
we're gonna get rid of you we're gonna
get rid of you we're gonna plant the
rest of these things cuz I know we got
more of those how we doing on food good
Greg Greg Greg great okay they're rid of
you get rid of you plant you plant you
go away I don't want to reject all get
out of there get out of there I don't
you that's gone this is gone
I'll listen to the music that's some
nice music we're gonna pull one of these
here we're gonna wall this off as if it
never existed because there never did it
we're all just gonna pretend like it's
not there yeah that's how I'd like to
deal with all my problems so I think
once I do that
and then I'm gonna figure out why this
one is not a room oh it's not an
enclosed space yet oh well this is
priorities because I am an impatient son
of a [ __ ]
now hopefully once that's enclosed it'll
be hunky-dory and everything will be
wonderful yeah I say that about all my
things everything will be hunky-dory
when I just get this one thing to fix it
oh I can't wait for everything to be
solved man life is such a wonderful
adventure ain't it [ __ ] we got to get it
yeah get all this [ __ ] in the
refrigerator I said I got to get more
refrigerator anyway
yeah not a Y then why does the goddamn
refrigerator take so much goddamn power
Oh actually no they reduce it I think
they've reduced it actually because it
used to take it like 240 watts yeah now
it's only 120 watts hell yeah
okay so [ __ ] the ration box we don't
need that if you get the ration box
prizes whoa exosuit overlay okay all
right sure
yeah salmon recovery bonus that's good
cuz we got a Brax oh hell yeah hell yeah
okay so now that we got that that's good
which means they we're gonna be able to
have a little bit of a stamina bonus
we're gonna have this is this a room yet
yes mess-hall baby all right everybody's
got tables - we're not gonna get any
more people than six so that's all we
need so row and are you happy finally
arey meemaw I know me ma you've seen
pretty much everything and nothing
shocks you at this point but yeah I got
it miss not bad right me Mom it's not
bad yeah whatever they'll get it why is
Oh goddamn why is it there please get
this at a level six priority so that you
dump out the pissed water thank you
no oh good actually that's good you
picked that up and then you wash your
hands it's good it's very good okay
nice bathroom is it really a nice
bathroom no no if she I don't know if
I'd call this bathroom nice it's got a
mediocre sculpture here there
quaint hmm masterpieces now one of these
days are gonna get that underway because
we do need more uh actually no wait it's
just said we didn't need more oxygen oh
the cycle is over so wouldn't have said
anyway did all this did all those
hatches like move up or something no no
no okay so what are we doing on research
we're almost at transit tubes but I
still don't think we're gonna be able to
build that because there's uh I they're
probably just gonna all need plastic and
in order to get plastic we need to get
oil and in order to get oil we need to
dig way too deep just we can't do it so
that's gonna come way way way later but
for now we make do okay we're off our
oxygen target by just a little bit if we
do that I can get rid of some of these
which means it will save water overall
because water I'm still a little bit
worried about water I mean water is
gonna be a little bit better with
filtration systems and all that stuff
but I'd rather not push it you know to
the limit you know I don't want I don't
want to give and I'm gonna give myself a
heart attack here just over water which
is always what happens because this
whole place like every little bit of it
like if there if you don't have water
like now you're so incredibly boned like
this non-stop just boned hundred twenty
watts
hey they dropped the power requirement
that one to hell yeah I mean about damn
time
Oh also I should replace these with the
bigger battery that would be smart of me
oh no you're not gonna be able to do
your research
No okay put that there there we go
stinky what are you doing
stinky stop that stinky stop stop it's
not built yet Diggy
what are you doing right who's wait
let's see if we can refine the jobs down
because if we're only gonna have six and
I'm definitely gonna want to try to
we're find that no one's really the best
at building well let's make sure Rowan
doesn't build that Rowan's digging let's
make sure who's bad at digging Frankie
you know dig ladies guys dig deliver
you're not very meemaw I love you to
death really do we all do everyone here
does love you to death but you're not
very athletic so we're gonna I'm gonna
take you off the delivery clue if that's
if that's okay all right okay all right
then pretty sure you're gonna be fine at
that
okay farming I didn't even know farming
was farming is a different skill that
used to be digging okay well I guess
that's good wait why are they stifled
cuz there's not enough oxygen did you
get this going yet god damn it you
didn't you didn't you didn't you didn't
you sack of [ __ ] you didn't priority 9
baby priority 9 that bad boy all right
get that
whirlybird going get that out of there
we need to get more airflow tiles um we
need airflow into there well these
pneumatic doors are just like they allow
air through so it's not really that bad
but we should at least get air flow
tiles going up through the top if this
is gonna be the way I think this is
gonna be at least space them out a
little bit goodly I don't like right
there there and there and yeah that'll
do okay
they should have an air we go there we
go that a baby oh that's barely any
power oh that's a thing of beauty right
there I know it's gonna cause some heat
but yeah you know c'est la vie c'est la
Heat it is what it is and we can't deal
with it right now but what we will deal
with in the future is everything else so
we got a fridge or we got two fridges up
and running which means that we got our
food being refrigerated which means that
that's gonna be not a problem for the
immediate future we've got enough meal
life being male life's being produced we
will eventually get rid of these and
we'll move them elsewhere because that's
not exactly the best place for them but
it is good enough for now and then we've
got another water supply over here but
that might be contaminated oh no that's
right cuz slime lung can't
travel through water food poisoning can
and does slime lung only travels in air
and solid but it does not affect water
so slime lung is never a factor when
you're dealing with filtration through
the polluted water in there the next
step will be to get filtration system it
looks like there's a good bit over here
and I will get that underway for that
one but that is all the time that I got
for this episode so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you think down the comments below I am
gonna play more of this because I just
freaking love the game you know I just
love love love the game so much and I
can't help but love it cuz there's so
much to love about it so thank you
everybody so much for watching we are
gonna survive this one we're gonna be
we're gonna be building a colony that is
gonna be worthy of the markable our name
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]